[Musik]
Deutschlands Schulen sind im Schnitt
nicht besonders gut zu schlecht
jedenfalls für das Selbstverständnis
einer führenden Industrienation denn den
Ansprüchen an eine zeitgemäße Bildung im
21 Jahrhundert werden Sie kaum gerecht
was läuft hier schief und woran egt es
dass obwohl die Probleme seit langer
Zeit bestens bekannt sind sich so wenig
zum Guten verändert welche ganz
konkreten Schritte müsste man tun damit
die Dinge sich zum Guten wenden darüber
rede ich mit dem Bildungsforscher
Andreas Schleicher Direktor für Bildung
bei der
OECD Herr Schleicher vor 22 Jahren haben
sie der deutschen Öffentlichkeit die
erste Pisastudie vorgestellt seitdem ist
viel Zeit vergangen wenn sie sich damals
überlegt haben wie die Schulen in
Deutschland wohl in 22 Jahren aussehen
würden ist das so gekommen wie sie sich
das gedacht haben oder ganz anders ich
hätte mir gewünscht dass die die Schüler
wirklich mehr im Vordergrund stehen dass
es uns besser gelingt alle Schüler
irgendwo mitzunehmen zu erkennen wie
verschiedene Menschen unterschiedlich
lernen und ich glaub das ist uns nicht
gelungen was glauben Sie woran es liegt
dass Ihre Erwartungen nicht erfüllt
worden sind wir haben immer noch ein
sehr stark vertikal ausgerichtetes
Bildungssystem irgendjemand denkt sich
aus was junge Menschen lernen sollen
dann bilden wir Lehrkräfte aus das
umzusetzen und am Ende sind die Schüler
so zu Konsumenten
vorgefertigter Lerninhalte geworden und
ich glaube das passt nicht mehr in
unsere Zeit heute brauchen wir Schüler
Lehrkräfte die zu innovativen Designern
von modernen Lernumgebung werden und wir
brauchen mehr horizontale Struktur
Lehrkräfte die gemeinsam im Team
arbeiten Schulen die irgendwo
voneinander miteinander lernen
Bildungssysteme die mehr nach außen
gerichtet sind wo die Schulen sind
meistens gut darin die Schüler drin zu
halten und den Rest der Welt draußen ich
glaube diese Verbindung müssen wir
schaffen und dann kann das auch gelingen
die Schwierigkeit scheint ja darin zu
bestehen dass die heute bestehenden
Schulen dass die in einer Zeit ersonnen
worden sind als die diese Ansprüche die
sie gerade formuliert haben die
Ansprüche des 21 jahrhunderts was man
heute können muss als sie noch gar keine
Rolle spielten sondern als man brave
Untertanen hervorbringen wollte die man
für bestimmte Aufgaben gebrauchen konnte
die man sortiert hat also die Schulen
sind etwas vergröber und gesagt ja nach
dem Vorbild des Militärs entstanden auch
dass es drei Laufbahnen gibt ne also die
Volksschule ursprünglich die
Grundausbildung für alle und dann gab's
für die Schreibstube gab's dann die
Mittelschule oder Realschule und für die
offizierslau aufubahn gab's das
Gymnasium und wichtig war dass man gut
funktionierte in seiner Rolle und nicht
dass man selbstbestimmt war oder
selbstreflektiert sondern dass man gut
ins System und ins Schema passte das
spielte ja eine riesige Rolle jetzt
haben die Schulen heute eine ganz andere
Aufgabe aber die Systemarchitektur die
ist ja im Prinzip immer noch die gleiche
das heißt also wie kann der neue Inhalt
in das alte System geht das überhaupt ja
ich glaube wirklich die wir haben im
Grunde ist nicht unbedingt militärisch
aber industriell geprägtes
Bildungssystem ist sehr instrumentell
ausgelegt ich lerne für etwas für einen
Job ich lerne um mich an bestehende
Strukturen im Grunde anzupassen und so
ist das Bildungssystem auch konzipiert
und wir leben heute in einer Welt wo die
Dinge die man leicht unterrichten kann
die kann man auch leicht digitalisieren
ich glaube das geht uns verloren in der
realen Welt Menschen müssen heute nicht
das Wissen unser Zeit reproduzieren
sondern in Frage stellen und neues
Wissen schaffen und
äh dafür die Welt belohnt uns nicht mehr
allein für das was wir wissen ne google
weiß alles sondern für das was wir mit
dem was wir wissen dann auch tun und tun
können und dafür gibt das
bildersystem zu wenig Raum wir haben
nicht nur eine Industrialisierung des
Bildungssystems gesehen Menschen
kompatibel zu machen mit den Normen der
Industriegesellschaft sondern auch eine
kommodifizierung Schüler werden zu
Konsumenten die Lehrkräfte werden zu
Dienstleister die Eltern werden zu
Kunden dieses Bildungssystem hat im
Grunde das hat das Herz des
Bildungssystem rausgenommen wir sind im
Grunde alle Beteiligte dieses
Bildungssystems jeder lernt ne wenn sie
vom industriellen lernen sprechen oder
die die Vorbereitung für die
Wirtschaftswelt wir haben eine Debatte
die es ist fast so alt wie die
Bildungsdebatte und sie besteht immer
noch und sie ist immer noch so
unaufgeräumt glaube ich wie sie immer
schon war und das ist die Frage wofür
ist Bildung eigentlich gut ja also ist
ist Bildung das was willlhel von Humbold
damals vorschwebte möglichst viele
Menschen dazu zu befähigen in einem
bürgerlichen Staat freidenkende
Staatsbürger zu sein ja was also für für
für Humbold die eine Hälfte war die eine
Hälfte war eine bürgerliche Gesellschaft
zu ermöglichen die jetzt sehr viel mehr
gebildete Leute brauchte aber er wollte
ja auch dass Staatsbürger entstehen die
eine Öffentlichkeit bilden können also
die miteinander über die Geschicke des
Staates und der Welt diskutieren können
die gebildet sind die eine geschulte
Urteilskraft haben das wäre ja so das
eine Ideal von Bildung und das andere
Ideal von Bildung ist die Engführung auf
Ausbildung die Frage was brauchen wir in
Zukunft für Arbeitskräfte und wie
schaffen wir das unsere Schulen so pas
genau wie möglich zu machen um
zukünftigen Arbeitsmärkten die
geeigneten Arbeitskräfte zuzuführen
welche dieser beiden Definitionen liegt
ihnen näher am Herzen oder welche halten
sie für klüger und das bessere
Bildungsziel eins ist klar die zweite
Version funktioniert heute nicht mehr ne
wir müssen Menschen für Arbeit bilden
die es heute noch nicht gibt für
Technologien die noch nicht erfunden
sind für soziale Herausforderung die wir
heute noch nicht erkennen insofern diese
dieses diese Idee dass wir die Welt von
morgen projektizieren können und dann im
Grunde Menschen dafür ausbilden das hat
heute keine Zukunft mehr nicht ich denke
die Frage ist wie können wir Menschen
bilden mit sich selber zu Leben zu leben
mit Menschen die anders sind als sie zu
leben mit diesem Planeten und das heißt
eben auch bessere abwegung zu treffen
zwischen der der Gegenwart ich tue alles
was mir die Gegenwart ermöglicht und der
der Zukunft ich ich setze mich dafür ein
dass das Nachhaltigkeit zum Ziel wird
also ich glaube das sind die großen
Herausforderungen unserer Zeit und D das
fertigwissen das muss ich mir im Kontext
erarbeiten heute im Grunde muss ich mein
Lebens mein Leben lang mein Horizont aus
und umbauen können nicht einfach im
Grunde Menschen vorbereiten auf eine
bestim bestimte Berufs die können wir
heute nicht mehr kennen das ist im
Grunde die die Chance auch unserer Zeit
dass Bildung uns wirklich zum zum
Menschen macht das ist glaube ich das
das der Kern die
Kernaufgabe also ich weiß dass viele
Vertreter der Wirtschaft und ich habe ja
selber m mit dem bildungsthema
beschäftigt und bin viel in der
Wirtschaft unterwegs gewesen eigentlich
immer noch die Anforderung haben zu
sagen wir werden einen Mangel an
Informatikern haben den haben wir jetzt
schon ja da brauchen wir mehr Leute und
wir brauchen in Zukunft deutlich mehr
Leute die bereit sind Altenpfleger zu
werden und so weiter und das ist ja die
Aufgaben der Schulen sein muss in
irgendeiner Form diese Situation zu
antizipieren darauf hin zuuarbeiten dann
hat es kurzfristige Initiativen geben z
die mininitiative wo man gesagt hat also
es wird in Zukunft entscheidend für den
Wirtschaftsstandort Deutschland sein
dass wir viele spitzeninformatiker haben
und der Gedanke dahinter war wir müssen
die Naturwissenschaften in den Schulen
stärken das bedeutete den Pflichtanteil
für jeden Schüler an Naturwissenschaften
zu erhöhen mit der Folge dass wir
natürlich Schüler haben die nicht die
geringste Affinität zu
Naturwissenschaften haben und bei denen
die Wahrscheinlichkeit dass sie ihr
Abitur nicht schaffen ihr Klassenziel
nicht erreichen dadurch enorm gestiegen
sind obwohl diese sowieso nie gute
Informatiker geworden wären das heißt
wir haben eigentlich doch ein System das
immer noch so in mit der giekanne drüber
geht oder das versucht zu normieren die
Alternative dazu würde ja darin bestehen
dass man den Mathematikunterricht den
Pflichtanteil reduziert dass man
vielleicht auch die begabten Schüler von
den weniger begabten Schülern trennt
damit die jeweils quasi adäquate
Lernumgebung haben also erer
projektorientiert das ganze
macht wie positionieren Sie sich DAU sie
sind selber Naturwissenschaftler sie hab
Mathematik studiert wie würden Sie z.B
das amstrittenste Fach an deutschen
Schulen Mathematik was würden Sie da
ändern oder ganz konkret anders machen
ja ich glaub Mathematik und
Naturwissenschaften sind in dieser Welt
von enormer Bedeut
aber auch das sollten wir nicht
instrumentalisieren wir sollten nicht
daran denken wie viele Menschen wir
brauchen in bestimmten Fächern in der
Zukunft s einfach Menschen die heute den
Klimawandel verstehen wollen müssen dass
die Idee einer Exponentialfunktion
verstehen können das geht gar nicht
darum zu berechnen damit verbringen wir
den Großteil unserer Zeit das aber das
machen heute Computer aber das Konzept
zu verstehen ist wichtig ne wenn ich und
es entgeht uns als Menschen das ist
nicht intuitiv ne unsere Zeit und Raum
sind lineare Konzepte in dieser bewegen
wir uns gerne aber wenn ich eine die
Idee einer Exponentialfunktion verstehen
muss dann muss ich wie ein Mathematiker
denken können und ich glaube es geht bei
Naturwissenschaft und Mathematik darum
weniger Stoff in größerer Tiefe zu
vermitteln ne also ich muss sagen aber
machen wir nicht gerade das Gegenteil
also ich meine sie sie haben Kinder in
der Schule gehabt mein Sohn hat vor
einem Jahr die Schule verlassen wenn ich
mir mich frage was ist der Unterschied
gewesen zu früher dann würde ich sagen
insgesamt ist das Leistungsniveau die
Anforderung leicht gesunken aber die
Summe die Menge an Stoff der bearbeitet
werden muss ist stark gestiegen aber das
ist das also genau gegenteilig zu dem
was sie sich eigentlich wünschen das ist
das Problem nicht die Lösung ich ich ich
selber bin Naturwissenschaftler mir
bricht das das Herz wenn ich sehe wie
wir Naturwissenschaft wie Religion
unterrichten wir versuchen Kindern
irgendwo eine Theorie beizubringen der
glaubt da dran und dann bringen wir uns
viele Beispiele bei und rechnet das und
am Ende müss die Antworten die wir
vorher gewusst habenod
das ist das Problem das nicht die Lösung
als Naturwissenschaftler geht es nicht
darum Massen an physikalischen
chemischen Wissen zu erarbeiten sondern
kann ich ein Experiment konzipieren kann
ich fragen die sich
naturwissenschaftlich beantworten lassen
unterscheiden von fragen wo das nicht
der Fall ist ne das ist Geschichte ne in
Geschichte geht's nicht darum jetzt
Massen auswendig zu lernen von en Zeiten
Person sondern kann ich wie ein
Historiker denken verstehe ich wie wie
das narrativ einer Gesellschaft
entstanden ist wie es sich entwickelt
hat weiterentwickelt hat und manchmal in
sich zusammenfällt wenn der konex sich
ändert diese Konzepte diese Ideen der
Fächer und projektorientierter
Unterricht heißt ja auch das dann
zusammenzuführen kann ich vielleicht
auch aus der aus der aus der aus der
engen Zelle ja wenn sie sprachen von
Religion ich sag mal aus der engen
Klosterzelle eines Fachs auszubrechen ja
ja so ich meine der Klimawandel der der
ist kein Fach sondern da da sind lauter
Dinge daran beteiligt also da macht man
geographische Kenntnisse die man dafür
haben muss physikalische Kenntnisse
dafür haben man muss aber auch
Kenntnisse von sozialen Fragen
Soziologie Sozialpsychologie haben um
diese ganzen Prozesse zu verstehen jetzt
hat die Schule natürlich ein Problem
weil sie hat ausgebildete Lehrer für das
und für das für manche dieser Dinge gibt
es nicht mal sind es ist nicht kann man
nicht mal auf Lehramt studieren das heiß
die Schulen sind ja relativ überfordert
damit diese Ideen die ja vielleicht auch
von vielen Lehrern begrüßt werden auch
tatsächlich umzusetzen also ich glaube
das muss nicht so zu sein also ich
glaube schon wichtig dass Lehrkräfte
wirklich ihr Fach wirklich von Grund auf
verstehen und auch auch eine
Begeisterung dafür mitbringen ich glaube
das ist das was wir als Schüler als
erstes merken ist das wirklich ein
Mensch vor mir der sich der in diesem
Fach drin lebt ne dann aber muss es auch
möglich sein über die fächering Grenzen
hinwg zu arbeiten warum arbeitet der die
Geschichtslehrerin nicht zusammen mit
dem der mathematiklehren an
problemorientierten Unterricht an Themen
wie dem Klimawandel ich glaube es geht
nicht darum die Dinge zu verflachen oder
miteinander zu mischen sondern dass ich
als Schüler
über die Fächergrenzen hinwegdenken kann
dass ich im Grunde Probleme aus
verschiedenen blickwi Blickwinkeln
irgendwo betrachten kann wenn uns das
gelingt dann machen wir das Leben für
die Schüler spannend dann arbeite ich an
Themen mit verschiedenen Perspektiven
mit verschiedenen Lehrkräften wir machen
die Arbeit für die Lehrkräfte spannend
ich muss nicht jeden Tag das gleiche
unterrichten das gleiche Fach sondern
ich arbeite mit Menschen zusammen die
die Welt aus anderen Gesichtspunkten her
betrachten und das glaube ich wird
Unterricht spannender machen Realität
anwendungsbezogener wird das
Unterrichten spannender machen das wird
auch den Lehrerberuf letztendlich in der
Attraktivität Stärken ma also spannend
ist der wichtige Begriff den ich gehört
habe zu spannend gehört intrinsische
Motivation ich muss etwas spannend
finden und jetzt haben wir das Problem
dass Kinder in dem Alter in den sie
Schule kommen schon aus
entwicklungspsychologischen Gründen
einen unglaublichen Hunger auf die Welt
haben sie wollen alles erkunden ertasten
sie wollen ganz ganz viel Wissen dem in
die Schule kommen stellen Sie die
meisten Fragen es ist natürlich dass
dieser Prozess irgendwann im Laufe des
Lebens weniger wird aber es ist schade
dass er in dem Ausmaß verloren geht wie
das in einer normalen Schulkarriere der
Fall ist wo man eigentlich älter man
wird umso weniger wissen will also
besteht ja die schwierige Aufgabe darin
diesen unendlichen Schatz der
intrinsischen Motivation soweit es
irgendwo geht zu pflegen jetzt besteht
aber auch das Problem der Schulen darin
dass das viel schwieriger ist als früher
früher war die extrinsische Motivation
ja auch stärker das heißt also die Angst
vor dem Lehrer vor dem Druck vor dem
Versagen vor der Reaktion der Eltern da
das Gott sei Dank sehr viel weniger
geworden ist müsste ja im gleichen Maße
bei der intrinsischen Motivation
aufgerüstet werden aber sind unsere
Schulen so wie sie gegenwärtig sind
dafür eigentlich gut geeignet ich frage
mich manchmal wenn es gar keine Schulen
gäbe als
Gedankenexperiment und man denkt sich
wir müssen mal Schulen erfinden für die
Herausforderung vor der wir heute in der
Gesellschaft stehen die hätten
wahrscheinlich in ihrer ganzen
Systemarchitektur doch kaum etwas mit
dem gemeinsamen wie heute eine normale
Schule aussieht ja ich meine Bildung ist
nie Transaktion Bildung ist immer
Beziehungsarbeit ich lerne von und mit
Menschen ihr Lieblingsfach in der
Grundschule hat wahrscheinlich weniger
mit dem Inhalt zu tun als mit der
Lehrkraft die die vor ihnen stand ne und
Kinder werden mit einem Unmaß an
Kreativität geboren wenn Sie eine
dreijährige Sohn oder Tochter haben die
Stellen alles in Frage was sie ihn
erzählen die sind Experimentieren mit
allem was ihnen in die Hände kommt die
sind immer bereit zu lernen auch wieder
Dinge neu und umzulernen und in der
Schule versuchen wir dann kompatibel zu
machen mit bestehenden Strukturen
teilweise machen wir schaen wir sogar
Nachteile für junge Menschen wenn sie
wissen in Frage stellen und die sind
unbequem oder passen sie nicht an
Strukturen und insofern dann geht uns
das verloren aber das ist gar nicht so
schwer das das zu ändern ich glaube
junge Menschen wenn wir Spann Aufgaben
ich glaube der Ansatz liegt daran dass
wir mehr Raum schaffen des Lehrkräfte
sehen wer sind meine Schüler eigentlich
wer sind diese Menschen wer wollen sie
werden wie kann ich sie auf ihrem
Lebensweg begleiten und wir haben im
Grunde auch dort für die Lehrer diesen
Raum immer eingeengt ne ich muss ein
fachunterrichten und wir sehen in in
vielen erfolgreichen Bildungssystem wen
nach Ostasien schauen da wird vielleicht
eine Stunde weniger unterrichtet aber es
gibt sehr viel mehr Zeit der Lehrkräfte
für den einzelnen Schüler außerhalb des
klassenverbands die die kennen ihre
Kinder die wissen wer sie sind die
wissen im Grunde wie aus welchem
Elternhaus sie kommen und ich glaube das
ist wirklich wichtig dass wir dort mehr
Raum für diese Beziehungsarbeit schaffen
soziale emotionale Kompetenz ja sagt ihn
heute jeder das ist das das Kern die der
KE der Zukunft Beziehungsarbeit
Beziehungskultur wichtige Schlagworte in
der Bildungsdiskussion wenn ich eine
normale Schule habe und ich habe 500
oder 1000 Schüler und da drüber
irgendwie 100 Lehrer und äh ein Direktor
da drüber wie soll da Beziehungsarbeit
oder Beziehungskultur eigentlich
funktionieren da kommt ein Chemielehrer
der hat übernimmt eine Klasse für ein
Jahr und meiner Schulzeit war das so bei
meinem Sohn wiederholte sich das der
weiß dann am Ende nicht mal so ganz
genau wenn er die Noten verteilen muss
wer wä eigentlich war ja weil er hier
unterrichtet er und da unterrichtet da
ist er mal kurz und so ich meine es gab
doch so viele oder es gibt doch so viele
Ideen wie man die Anonymität der SCH
Schule aufbrechen könnte etwa das
englische collegeesystem also warum
unter teilt man die Schule nicht in
lernhäuser Griffindor slitherin und die
Aufgabe eines jeden zuständigen tutors
und eines jeden Lehrers der in einem
Lernhaus ist es die Kinder des
jeweiligen lernhauses soweit wie möglich
zu bringen solche Modelle gibt es gibt's
im Ausland häufiger als in Deutschland
warum sieht nicht jede normale Schule in
Deutschland längst so aus ja ich wollte
gerade sagen also das Problem was Sie
beschreiben haben wir uns selber
geschaffen das liegt nicht daran dass es
zu wenig Personal gibt es gibt im Grunde
gute Betreuungsschlüssel ist eine Frage
im Grunde wir haben das alles auf
gesplittet ne sie ich ma den Unterricht
sie sind der schubpsychologe dann haben
wir noch hoozialarbeiter jeder arbeitet
an einem kleinen Teilbereich wie am
fließban ne und um den Menschen der die
Menschen gehen dort verloren wenn sie in
eine Schule in Hongkong gehen das erste
was passiert die Schulleiterin der
Schulleiter steht am schult und begrüßt
jedes Kind mit Namen auch dort gibt's
1000 2000 Kinder in der Schule aber das
ist denen wichtig darum geht es es gibt
Möglichkeiten für die Kinder nachmittags
ihre Lehrer zu treffen Fragen zu stellen
mit denen gemeinsam zu arbeiten in Japan
machen die Lehrkräfte am Ende des
Schultages noch die Klassenzimmer sauber
mit ihren Schülern nicht weil sie die
Reinigungskraft sparen sondern weil wir
sind alle das ist unser Projekt diese
Schule wir arbeiten daran insofern das
kann man anders gestalten und man muss
auch sagen bei den Lehrkräften ab wenn
man Menschen darauf vorbereitet
Hamburger aufzuwärmen dann werden sie
nie zum Meisterkoch und das fehlt uns
Grunde dieses im Grunde ich bin wirklich
Spezialist ich muss die die meine
Lernumgebung selber im Grunde
konstruieren mit meinen Schülern
gemeinsam ne die intrinsische Motivation
kommt daher dass ich als Schüler auch
wirklich beteiligt bin ganz spannendes
Beispiel also man hat ähnlich
verkrustete Strukturen in Portugal
gehabt ne das war auch ein sehr vertikal
ausgerichtetes bürokratisches
Schulsystem hat man irgendwann gesagt
okay wir gehen jer Schule Schule 1 € pro
Schüler extra aber dieser Euro wird von
den Schülern ausgegeben die Schüler
konnten also selber entscheiden im
Grunde wie sie diese Ressourcen
einsetzen sehr begrenzte Mittel gewesen
es hat zu Mentalitätswandel geführt
plötzlich waren die Schüler Akteure
nicht im Grunde Konsumenten sie waren
Gestalter sie haben dann auch bei der
Schulleitung nachgefragt warum leckt das
hier durch das Dach oder warum haben
bestimmte Schüler nicht die Schulmittel
plötzlich hat sich das Verhältnis
verschoben alle waren Beteiligte und so
kann man Dinge verändern ich glaube es
gar nicht so so schwer das zu tun aber
wir haben uns diese Problematik selber
geschaffen dies diese dieser
industrielle Ansatz der der Menschen zu
zu Funktion reduziert anstatt im Grunde
zu sehen wir können wir Menschen bilden
sie sind Direktor bei der OECD sie haben
einen vergleichenden Blick auf Schulen
wie wenig andere sie können also aus
einer ganz großen breiten Palette
erzählen was sie gerade ja auch
ansatzweise gemacht haben ich würde
gerne mal wissen wie kommen andere
Länder zu ihren Lehrern also wer wird
aus welchen Gründen Lehrer und wie wie
verhindert man dass Leute die in der
Schule unterrichten für dafür nicht
geeignet sind weil die Quote derjenigen
dürfte nicht gering sein und die zweite
Frage ist wenn es gar nicht so viele
begabte und geeignete Lehrer gibt wer
sollte denn sonst in der Schule
unterrichten auf die erste Frage würde
ich eigentlich immer gerne den Vorschlag
machen das ist ja auch mal experimentell
durchgespielt worden ich glaube in
Passau vor einiger Zeit dass man gesagt
hat man müsste Lehrer eigentlich Ksten
denn man kann darüber streiten was die
wichtigste Eigenschaft eines Lehrers ist
viele Leute meinen dass er Kinder liebt
ich persönlich bestreite das weil ich
würde sagen die Lehrer von denen ich am
meisten gelernt habe waren nicht
unbedingt die nettesten ich glaube die
wichtigste Voraussetzung eines Lehrers
ist dass man ihm gerne zuhört weil man
sonst nichts lernen kann und eigentlich
weiß man das schon ziemlich früh ob man
die Begabung hat dass man andere Leute
fesseln und in den Band schlagen kann
oder nicht jetzt könnte man ja hingehen
und sagen wenn jemand ein
Lehramtsstudium aufnimmt dass er zum
frühest möglichen Zeitpunkt damit er
nicht also allzu lange in die Irre läuft
vor eine große Klasse gestellt wird und
dann zu einem zu einem Thema seiner Wahl
wenn er Geschichtslehrer werden will und
man setzt ih an siebte oder sechste
Schuljahr vor und er erzählt was über
die Goldene Bulle dass er das macht und
dass man eigentlich wie bei jeder
castingsh schon nach zi bis 3 Minuten
weiß der wird bestimmt mal ein guter
Lehrer oder der sollte vielleicht was
anderes machen warum gibt es ein solches
lehrercting in Deutschland nicht und
gibt's das in anderen Ländern wenn sie
nach Finnland gehen ist das ganz
selbstverständlich ne sie können am
Anfang machen Sie ein Eingangstest um im
Studium reinzukommen aber von neun von
zehn Bewerbern wird einer ausgewählt in
der Praxis durch ein das ist kein
Casting im direkt aber die müssen sich
in den Schulen in der Praxis bewren im
zweiten Jahr das erste Jahr Studium das
zweite Jahr ist Bewährung in der Praxis
kann ich mit Menschen arbeiten kann ich
mit meinen Kollegen arbeiten das ist das
entscheidende Kriterium also es gibt's
durchaus man muss sich ja fragen in
Deutschland die Lehrkräfte werden gut
bezahlt es gibt kein Land in der OECD
das so hohe lehrergehälte hat und
trotzdem lafen uns die Leute Weg der
Beruf ist finanziell attraktiv aber
intellektuell nicht attraktiv in Findern
sind die Lehrergehälter viel niedriger
und die haben zehn Bewerber auf jede
Lehrerstelle warum ist ein so spannender
Beruf ich kann jeden Tag mit meinen
Kollegen die Welt neu erfinden ich bilde
mich jeden Tag weiter ich lerne von und
mit meinen Kollegen ich kann die
Lernumgebung selber umgestalten das
macht diesen Beruf attraktiv da muss man
anfangen wenn der Beruf nicht attraktiv
ist gewinnen sie keine Leute dafür auch
bei hohen
Gehältern Geld ist immer ein demotivator
ne wenn die Leute nicht vernünftig
bezahlen laufen sie ih weg aber es nie
ein
intrinsischer die schafft nie diese
intrinsische Motivation würden sie
Lehrer verwen das muss nicht sein ich
bin da im Grunde relativ neutral was
entscheidend ist dass dieser Lehrerberuf
offen ist ich würde sagen es sollten no
Menschen die vielleicht dieses Studium
nicht so abge durchgeführt haben Lehrer
werden können ja das ist doch Variante 2
oder warum hole ich denn also wenn ich
sageenn ich Lehrer kastte und es bleiben
wir haben jetzt schon Lehrermangel und
dann bleiben noch weniger übrig die in
die Schulen kommen dann müssen wir das
doch auffüllen mit Leuten die
pädagogische Begabungen haben einen
pädagogischen fuhrohr haben das auch
wirklich zu wollen die aber vielleicht
keine Lehrerausbildung gemacht haben
also warum soll nicht jemand der ein
Startup gegründet haben Informatiker
unterrichten ein eben emeritierter Max
Planck institutsphysiker warum soll der
nicht die Leistungskurse zum Thema
Quantenmechanik Projekte machen warum
soll nicht ein KFZ Mechatroniker ein
Projekt Automotor in der Schule anbieten
oder ein Dichter Schülern beibringen wie
man Gedichte schreibt und ihnen dann
enon ja das Machwerk der
wissenschaftlichen Zergliederung an die
Hand geben Trochus Jambus anapest und
daktilus und nicht dass ein Lehrer die
Schüler damit traktiert was es alles an
wissenschaftlicher Zergliederung geht
und niemand ist klar wozu es gut ist und
auch wozu Gedichte gut sind also warum
öffnet man die Schulen nicht im großen
Stil für pädagogisch begabte Praktiker
warum findet das in Deutschland nicht
statt auch das gibt's schon teach for
all das ist eine internationale
Organisation die wählt sich brillante
junge Leute aus die was tun wollen für
unsere Gesellschaft aus welchem Fach
auch immer sie kommen und die schafft
für diese Menschen Möglichkeiten sich in
den Schulen einzusetzen für mindestens
zwei Jahre funktioniert sehr gut das
sind teilweise die beliebtesten
Lehrkräfte ne weil die irgendwo auch
junge Menschen sehen ist das jemand der
wirklich für seinen Fach steht der auch
praktische Erfahrung gesammelt hat der
eben m ist und nicht über im Grunde
Mechatronik spricht ne und und das kann
man machen das gibt dafür gute
Möglichkeiten aber noch zu der anderen
Frage dass dieses Casting das Spielfeld
verengt ich glaube es ist umgekehrt je
spannender und je sorgfältiger wir
Menschen auswählen umso attraktiver wird
das Berufsfeld sehen Sie das im Casting
im im im Showbereich ne wie viele
Menschen bewerben sich weil der Job
interessant ist und da müssen wir
ansetzen dass wir praktisch nicht durch
das Casting noch mehr Leute aussieben
sondern dass wir da im Grunde das so
spannend machen dass jeder das machen
möchte und das wird das kann gelingen
wir haben ja jetzt bisher immer darüber
gesprochen was man tun müsste und wir
haben auch Beispiele genannt gerade sie
haben einige Beispiele genannt von
Ländern in denen das funktioniert oder
mit teach for all im Beispiel gebracht
das sozus Ansetzen so etwas ja schon
gibt was man allerdings wenn man meine
Fantasien umsetzen wollte in einem ganz
sehr viel größeren Maßstab statt
findinden müsste und auch nicht nur mit
jungen sondern es können ja auch ältere
Leute sein die Wölfe die viel Schnee
gesehen haben und viel zu erzählen haben
dass wir die in die Schulen bringen
jetzt sind ja viele von Dinge über die
wir hier reden ziemlich bekannt und
werden ja auch schon seit manches seit
Jahrzehnten anderes vielleicht seit 10
Jahren eingefordert und trotzdem bewegt
sich ja in der Breite in unserem
Schulsystem so wenig wer oder was bremst
diese notwendigen Veränderung aus ja
noch mal also wie kann man Dinge
verändern mal ein ganz praktisches
Beispiel wir haben über das Thema
gesprochen lernen relevanter zu machen
in England ist ist hat man vor dem
Problem gestanden dass Schüler in der
Schule so viel abstraktes Zeug lernen
und manchmal auch gerade die Schüler aus
sozialschwachen zusammenhängen da
einfach abgehängt werden für die die
erkennen die Relevanz nicht hat man
gesagt okay wir posten
mal im Web Anzeige wer ist bereit zi
Stunden pro Monat seiner Zeit
einzubringen in Schulen um Kindern
seinen eigenen Job zu erklären da
brauche ich nicht für studieren da muss
ich einfach im Grunde in die Schule
gehen sagen mache ich und so mache ich
das wir hatten damit gerechnet wir
kriegen vielleicht 500 oder 1000
bewerber können wir ein tolles
Experiment machen erster Durchgang 47
000 Freiwillige das gibt eine enorme
Bereitschaft in unser Gesellschaft
Bildung zum Thema der Gesellschaft zu
machen nicht ir Grunde zum
isolierten und als die Menschen in die
Schulen gekommen s dann hat man die
verknüpft also die Schule hat gewählt
das Fach die die Menschen die haben die
Welt verändert ne ich war selber auf
einer dieser Veranstaltungen da kam
Mädchen das war in der Grundschule dann
die die wichtigsten
Karriereentscheidungen die treffen sie
nicht am Ende der Schulzeit sondern zu
Beginn ihrer Schulzeit ne und das wird
also in der Grundschule gemacht
zehjähriges Mädchen kam zu mir und ich
habe sie gefragt war das interessant
hast du was neues gelernt und er sagte
mir ah das war so spannend ich wusste
nicht dass Frauen Elektriker werden
können ne und das in unserer
Gesellschaft in Europa also ich glaube
viele Dinge können wir praktisch
verändern indem wir die Gesellschaft
nicht zum Kunden machen sondern zum
Beteiligten zweiter Punkt inem wir
freier für die Schulen schaffen Tanker
ist schwer zu bewegen überall
schnellbote kann man leicht bewegen und
wir brauchen einfach mehr Gestalt Räume
wenn sie in Deutschland schauen 17%
aller Entscheidungen werden hier vor Ort
in den Schulen getroffen Nachbarland
Niederlande
von ze Entscheidung
93% dort sind die Schulen im Grunde ich
muss mir überlegen das ist meine
Schülerschaft das ist die Realität das
ist sind die Ressourcen die ich habe wie
kombiniere ich Raum Zeit Technologie
Beziehung um das Lernumfeld zu schaffen
was ich heute brauche und das diese
gestaltungsvorräume also irgendwo auf
nach oben zu setzen dass das irgendwo
langsam so durchsickert ne ich schaffe
heute neuen Bildungsstandards oder neue
neue Bildungspläne dann bilde ich
Lehrkräfte neu aus dann warte ich bis
diese Lehrkräfte irgendwann in den
Schulen sind 20 30 Jahre und am Ende
wirgt sich nichts weil wenn sie
motivierte Menschen in ein Schulsystem
bringen wo sie nichts bewegen können
entweder verlassen sie das oder sie
werden selber dem ert also aber wenn wir
all das Wissen und wenn jemand wie sie
eine Stimme mit Gewicht ja eindringlich
darauf hinweist und darauf hin wirkt
warum bewegt es sich nach wie vor so
langsam also warum sind wir immer noch
der Tanker und warum haben wir keine
schnellbote ja man muss ehrlich sein das
ist nicht einfach ne und teilweise sind
wir als Eltern auch Teil des Problems
nicht Teil der Lösung ne wir werden sehr
schnell nervös wenn unsere Kinder nicht
mehr das lernen was wichtig für uns war
oder wenn sie Dinge lernen die wir nicht
verstehen als Lehrkraft ist es immer
einfacher so zu unterrichten wie ich
selber unterrichtet wurde als was
moderne Pädagogik sagt und als Politiker
können Sie eine Wahl verlieren wenn
irgendwas schief läuft mit Bildung aber
sie gewinnen keine Wahl mit Bildung weil
das eben sehr lange dauert gute Ideen
umzusetzen was man braucht ist
wirkliches leadership Menschen die
bereit sind im Grunde das Richtige zu
tun sich dort einzusetzen und auf jeder
Ebene des ist Systems ne wenn sie
Lehrkräfte in einer Schule werden dann
innovativ wenn sie sehen ich habe eine
Schulleitung hier die die schätzt das
die unterstützt mich dabei die lässt
mich nicht alleine äh wenn die
Schulleitung sehen ich kann in der
Schule wirklich Dinge zu gestalten ich
kann mit meinen Schulleitern meinen
Kollegen arbeiten dann schaffen wir da
durch die Räume das das zeigen uns ja
auch in Deutschland viele Schulen dass
das machbar ist ich glaube wichtig ist
dass wir dafür im Grunde ein
Unterstützungssystem schaffen so dass es
systemisch wird und das in wir sehen
dafür international viele gute Beispiele
wenn sie nach Polen schauen nach nach
Portugal die Niederland Land ne die
Waren in in ähnlichen Punkten wie
Deutschland haben das aber durchaus
verändern können die asiatischen Länder
die sind auf einer ganz ganz anderen
Lernkurve dort ne also das was sie sagen
fordere ich ja auch seit 12 Jahren dass
die Kultusminister und schulminister die
Leine verlängern an der sie die Schulen
gängeln das heißt eine Reduzierung der
Einflusssphäre der
Kultusbürokratie das bedeutet aber
eigentlich von Politikern genau das zu
warten was sie als einziges nun wirklich
nicht machen können nämlich Macht aus
den Händen zu geben wir versuchen immer
noch und das war ja ist auch inolge der
Pisastudien Geschehen von oben die
Schulen zu verändern mit der erwartbaren
und immer gleichen Reaktion dass ein
großer Teil der Schulen sagt oh Gott
jetzt kommt schon wieder es wird einem
nicht erklärt warum man das machen soll
sondern es gibt neue Vorschriften neue
Vorgaben und da muss man wieder was
ändern was man nicht eingesehen hat und
an einem Prozess an dem man nicht
beteiligt gewesen ist jetzt wäre es ja
großartig wenn wir das was sie auch
fordern den Schulen die Möglichkeit
geben sich selbst zu transformieren ja
ich weiß das nicht also ich glaube so
schwer ist das alles gar nicht also ich
habe mir sehr sorgfältig das
Bildungssystem in Shanghai angeschaut
weil die in wenigen Jahren wirklich an
die Leistungsspitze gekommen sind und
vor allen Dingen gerade gut waren bei
den sozial Schwachen Schü haben eine
Plattform geschaffen wo die Lehrkräfte
ihre eigenen Ideen Projekte Konzepte
einstellen können und der Trick war die
haben das mit reputationsbasierten
metricken verknüpft das heißt je mehr
andere Lehrkräfte ihre Ideen runterladen
verbessern kritisieren umso mehr Ansehen
gewinnen sie im Bildungssystem am Ende
des Schuljahres fragt sie ihre
Schulleiterin Schulleiter nicht wir
haben sie ihre eigenen Kinder
unterrichtet in der Klasse sondern
welchen Beitrag haben sie geleistet zum
Bildungssystem wir machen das heute mit
mit Universitätsprofessoren auch in
Deutschland ganz gut ne die Leute
veröffentlichen weil sie und im Grunde
wir müssen einfach uns mehr dafür
einsetzen dass die guten Ideen anerkannt
werden dass die Menschen die Dinge
voranbringen Anerkennung finden und das
hat dort enorm funktioniert der zweite
Ansatz den man da gemacht hat war
einfach gesagt okay wir werden jede
Karriere im Grunde so inzentivieren dass
die Menschen an den schwierigsten
Schulen arbeiten das heißt wenn sie
jetzt Schulleiter sind an einer der
leistungsstärksten Schulen oder
wizeschulleiter sagen wir mal und sie
wollen immer gerne Schulleiter werden
dann wird in das Bildungssystem sagen
tolle Ambition unterstützen Sie dabei
aber helfen Sie uns zunächst einmal eine
der schwächsten Schulen voranzubringen
da gewinnt man diese Scouts aus den
leistungsfähigsten Schulen wenn sie
Lehrkraft sind die haben dort vier
verschiedene Stufen der Lehrkräfte Stufe
1 ambitioniert wollen auf Stufe 2 dann
sagt man ihnen okay arit sie mit den
Schülern die wirklich aus den
Brennpunkten kommen wo die sozialen
Herausforderung sind das heißt die Leute
sind die gewinnen die besten Lehrkräfte
für die schwierigsten Klassen und die
besten Schulleitung also man braucht da
keine gib schon gibt's ein Land das das
praktiziert das ist Beispiel Schanghai
Vietnam ganz ähnlich ne und die haben in
wenigen Jahren ihr Bildungssystem
grundlegend transformiert nicht indem
sie eine neue Funktion geschaffen haben
Scout s haben einfach die die
motiviertesten die besten Leute die
heute arbeiten dort eingesetzt wo sie am
meisten bewirken kann wenn sie Schüler
aus aus der aus dem Willen vitel haben
da bewegt die Schule sowieso sehr wenig
dort und insofern denke ich da gibt's
viele gute Ansätze und die
Ressourcen wenn Sie heute sagen würden
wir bezahlen die Schulen danach V welch
Herausforderung sich stehen plötzlich
wird es spannend interessant mich um die
schwierigsten Schüler zu kümmern ne ich
habe dann auch die Ressourcen dafür hat
Schweden so gemacht Schweden bezahlt
sogar die Lehrkräfte individuell das
heißt Schul Schulleitung müssen sich
überlegen was muss ich einsetzen damit
der Mann bei uns bleibt oder die Frau ja
wenn Sie jetzt an einer schwierigen
Schule sind müssen sie vielleicht ein
bisschen mehr bezahlen oder wenn Sie ein
fachunterrichten wo es nicht aber bei
uns ist es umgekehrt man wird an der
Hauptschule schlechter bezahlt als am
Gymnasium obwohl man an der Hauptschule
den deutlich schwierigeren Job macht ja
ich meine man muss es sagen Deutschland
W viele Ressourcen regressiv eingesetzt
aber das kann man leicht verändern das
ist etwas was warum hat das noch keiner
verändert also warum dämmert es einem
nicht dass in in Neuköln zu unterrichten
ein hundertm schwierigerer Job ist als
in einem Willen Vorort und in einem
Gymnasium also warum ist das ich meine
die Erkenntnis ist ja nicht neu also die
Erkenntnis dass wir desolate Schulen
haben und dass wir die besten Lehrer
eben nicht an den schwierigsten Schulen
haben diese Erkenntnis ist 10 20 Jahre
alt und es ist dennoch nichts passiert
ich habe immer das Gefühl D
schulminister Kultusminister da nicht
unter Selektionsdruck stehen also das
ist etwas etwas was sie nicht verändern
müssen weil niemand es wirklich
öffentlich von ihnen einfordert und das
was von außen keinen Druck macht darauf
reagiert im Regelfall die Politik ja
nicht ja ich ich denke mal vielleicht
ist sogar noch noch schlimmer in der
dass die Menschen die von diesem
Bildungssystem profitiert haben die
Realität dieses Bildungssystems kaum
sehen ich sag ihn das mal weil in der
ersten PIs Studie als wir diese großen
sozialen Disparitäten festgestellt haben
ich habe mit vielen kultuspolitikern
gesprochen die haben alle gesagt das
stimmt so nicht das kann so gar nicht
sein die sind natürlich alle aus dem
Gymnasium gekommen wo dieses Probleme
nicht gibt und das ist die Welt die die
Menschen kennen und ich die die die die
die Menschen die an diesem Bildungsystem
scheitern die haben eben kaum eine eine
Stimme aber das ist die Aufgabe der
Politik im Grunde alle sichtbar für
jeden diesen Raum zu schaffen und das
kann uns gelingen das zeigen uns die
leistungsfähigsten Bildungssysteme ne
und in der Vergangenheit konnte man
sagen okay dieses sortieren war okay wir
brauchten ja nur ein paar Leute die
irgendwo für alle Arbeiten oder für die
alle die Arbeit konzipieren heute
brauchen wir jeden das ist in im
Zeitalter der künstlichen Intelligenz
können wir uns das nicht mehr leisten im
Grunde dass Menschen hier unter die
Räder kommen wir wir wir brauchen aber
die die Realität sieht ja so aus dass im
Punkto Bildungsgerechtigkeit wir uns
rückwärts entwickeln also es war ja ein
großes Thema seit den 60er als Georg
Picht über die deutsche
Bildungskatastrophe gesprochen hat und
eben gesagt hat wir müssen auch
Arbeiterkinder bilden weil wir in eine
akademikergesellschaft reinkommen wo wir
es uns nicht leisten können dass 10%
Abitur machen dafür brauchen wir viel zu
viele Leute mit Abitur also hat man
gesagt wir müssen ganz breit schürfen ja
und wir müssen dann mit all dem was dann
passiert ist von von barföck bis über
die Möglichkeit von Hauptschule zu
Realschule zu wechseln und und und man
sich ganz viele Gedanken gemacht und in
den 80ern hatten wir so in etwa den
Höhepunkt der Bildungsgerechtigkeit
erreicht und waren in Europa einer der
eines der vorbildlichen Länder und
seitdem geht das ganze wieder rückwärts
ich erinnere mich noch Ende der 70er
Jahre da sang es man im grippstheater ja
in Berlin money ist geschickt und schlau
doch sein Vater ist beim Bau deshalb
geht er bis zur neunten Klasse nur
Monika ist öt und Faht doch Papi ist
Regierungsrat deshalb macht sie bald die
Abitur und da sind wir inzwischen wieder
gelandet und dann frage ich mich wenn
wir das alles doch mal begriffen haben
und alles mal besser gemacht wie kann
sich denn etwas so dermaßen intensiv in
die falsche Richtung entwickeln ohne
dass die Politik das gestoppt hat für
Bildungsgerechtigkeit müssen wir uns
jeden Tag neu einsetzen das ist nicht
etwas was uns zufällt das glaube ich
wirklich das große Thema in Bildung
genau wie mit
M man kann auch sagen wir werden alle im
Grunde geboren mit der Tendenz mit
Menschen zu leben die genauso aussehen
wie wir die genauso denken wie wir die
genauso arbeiten wie wir und die
Technologie verstärkt das heute noch es
braucht wirklich schwierige Arbeit mit
Menschen zu arbeiten die anders sind als
ich die aus anderen Traditionen anderen
Kulturen kommen und genauso sieht das im
Bildungsbereich aus Chancengerechtigkeit
ist esw das müssen wir uns jeden Tag neu
erarbeiten wenn wir dort nachlassen
bricht die Welt wieder auseinander und
in der Vergangenheit könnte man sagen
okay wir können damit leben mit den
Konsequenzen der Umverteilung wir nehmen
das Geld der Reichen geben es den Arm
das funktioniert heute nicht mehr
soziale Beteiligung ist das große Thema
unserer Zeit und für mich die
spannendsten Ergebnisse der PIs Studie
sind dass wir das erreichen können dass
wirklich wir das Potenzial aller jungen
Menschen wirklich einbringen
dies gesellscha also ich denke mal dass
viele von denen die in dieser
Gesellschaft verloren sind weil sie die
Schule ohne Abschuss verlieren
gleichzeitig ein hungriges Potenzial
haben was wir nicht nutzen ja weil es ja
sehr sehr häufig ist dass die die Kinder
der etablierten auch ihren Hunger
verlieren und dass ja eigentlich die
Kinder aus den sozial schwierigeren
Verhältnissen
den Bildungsbiografie bedingten größeren
Hunger haben die aber nicht abgeholt
werden und nicht ankommen und die in
unserem System nicht entsprechend
begleitet wurden also ich habe mir schon
manchmal gedacht muss man nicht eine
Akademie Gründen wo alle die die ohne
Bildung aufgewachsen sind und denen die
Schule keine Bildung gegeben hat sich
bewerben können und von denen werden die
hungrigsten und die cleversten genommen
ja aber von da aus natürlich auch ein
Innovationspotenzial ausgehen kann was
eben an vielen anderen Stellen nicht
nicht mehr nicht mehr da ist also diese
diese aber ich dann frage ich mich was
soll die Lobby dahinter sein also
diejenigen für die es doch läuft wo ihre
Kinder Abitur machen und die in die
guten Berufe kommen und die Juristen und
Ärzte werden warum sollten die ein
Interesse daran haben dass der untere
Teil der Gesellschaft und die die
gänzlich verloren gehen und das ist ja
eine sehr große Zahl die haben doch kein
echtes Interesse daran also ich habe
immer das Gefühl es ist so ein
sonntagsredentha aber die Lobby dahinter
hter echter Bildungsgerechtigkeit die
ist doch schwach in diesem Land ja also
es gibt solche Schulen col carand in in
Paris ne das ist eine Schule für
Menschen die es im Leben nicht in der
Schule nicht geschafft haben aber begabt
sind und dort in in in Technologie neun
von Zeh dieser Leute kriegen den
Traumjob nach einem Jahr großartig das
funktioniert das kann man gut machen ich
glaube auch die Zukunft wird uns in die
Hände spielen im Zeitalter der künstlich
Intelligenz werden formale Qualifikation
die ich irgendwo mir angesammelt habe
immer weniger wert und die Kompetenz was
kann ich in welchem Kontext wie fähig
bin ich im Grunde wie motiviert mit neue
Dinge zu erlernen das wird immer
wichtiger und insofern spielt uns die
Zeit glaube ich da irgendwo in in in die
Hände aber wir können uns das als
Gesellschaft einfach heute nicht mehr
leisten denn man muss sehen also die
sozialen Kosten steigen für Menschen die
sich in diese Gesellschaft nicht ein wir
sehen eine zunehmende ökonomische
Polarisierung wir sehen eine kulturelle
Polarisierung eine politische
Polarisierung alles sind folgen wir
haben im Grunde nur ein Instrument um
dieses
irgwe eine Grundlage zu schaen das
Bildung ne wir haben viele Instrumente
um am Ende umzuverteilen aber wir können
an den Ursachen von Ungleichheit nur
durch bessere Bildung arbeiten und
deswegen ist das so wichtig ansonsten
wird uns diese Welt die die
Trans die die die Kräfte die es
auseinanderziehen die werden immer
stärker da sollten Sie in einem zweiten
Leben Kultus oder schulminister werden
was wäre das erste was Sie tun würden
den Menschen Vorort zu vertrauen die die
Experten sind und so schwierig ist das
auch gar nicht sie haben vorhin von
macht Verlust gesprochen glaub das
Gegenteil ist der Fall mein Einfluss
wird steigen wenn die Leute die mit mir
arbeiten als als als Minister sollten
sich nicht fragen würde ich mich nicht
fragen wie viele Leute glauben an das
was ich ihnen erzähle oder Folgen meinen
meinen Instruktion sondern wie gut
können diese Menschen gemeinsam arbeiten
ne und was ist mit der in einer
Schulbürokratie denen sie äußerst
suspekt sind wenn sie mit großen
Veränderungen kommen weil das bedeutet
mehr Arbeit das bedeutet von ihnen
Kreativität zu verlangen und man wird im
Regelfall nicht kultusbürokrat weil man
immer schon ein enorm Hunger nach
Kreativität hatte das heißt Sie müssen
ja nicht alleine das ganze machen
sondern sie müssen einen großen schweren
Tanker ziehen wie motivieren Sie Leute
die gar nicht gewohnt sind ja kreativ zu
arbeiten dazu diesen Weg mit ihnen zu
gehen ja wenn wir auf der Führungsebene
mehr leadership haben wenn wir auf der
Ebene der Schulen mehr Kreativität
Verantwortung haben dann wird sich diese
Betonschicht in der Mitte irgendwann
auflösen da bin ich ganz von überzeugt
dass Menschen ich war mal in in einer
Schule in in in China das hat mich
absolut begeistert wie die dort mit
neuen Technologien Dinge völlig anders
gemacht haben andere Pädagog habe ich
die schulterin gefragt mensch das ist ja
toll dass in die Regierung dafür die
Möglichkeiten gibt die sagte mir nur
wissen Sie Herr Schleicher in China sind
viele Dinge nicht erlaubt aber viele
Dinge auch nicht verboten und in dieser
Grauzone können wir eigentlich alles
machen und das geht uns verloren dass
man eben man man glaubt an diese
Bürokratie anstatt zu sagen Mensch die
Leute sollen mich unterstützen dafür
sind sie da und ich messe den Wert
dieser Bürokratie an den an an dieser
Unterstützung ich glaube wir können viel
mehr Dinge verändern vor Ort als uns es
oft bewusst ist ne dieses dieser Glaube
an die Bürokratie ist eigentlich
schlimmer als die Bürokratie selber ne
Herr Schleicher ich danke Ihnen für das
[Musik]
Gespräch
connection Abed